hey guys, Pete here. I was doing some
research that led me back to the prince
that was promised theory so i thought
i'd make a video about it. the show
hasn't deviate much from the books in
regards to the prophecy itself other
than cutting out an important reference
to it in season two when Daenerys is in
the house of undying. during season six
it did reference the prophecy in
Mereen that isn't from the books
and there was a heavy-handed
reference in the tower of joy scene too.
so it certainly hasn't been cut
completely out. The first time we hear about
the prince that was promised in the
books is on that trip through the house
of undying when Dany sees her brother
Rhaegar with his wife Elia Martell and
their newborn son Aegon. he tells her he
is the prince that was promised and his
is the song of ice and fire. Rhaegar had
once thought he might be the prince that
was promised as did Maester Aemon but
later they decided that it would be his son.
the Targaryens believed that the
prince will be born of their line
because Rhaegar's grandfather Jahaerys
the second visited a woods witch
that told him that it would be that way
Jahaerys had his two children Rhaella and
Aerys, Danny's parents, wed because the
witch told him that the prince would
come from their line. We don't know where
the prophecy started as there isn't much
information about it that we can draw
from. based on the fact that Maester
Aemon mentions a thousand years to
Samwell it should be safe to say that that
the prophecy is at least that old
according to Melisandre the prince that
was promised's coming was prophesized over
5,000 years ago but she doesn't make any
mention of who made the actual prophecy
Melisandre sort of uses the prince that
was promised an Azor Ahai interchangeably
but we hear her say Azor Ahai far
more often. on the other hand Aemon never
mentions the name Azor Ahai when he's
talking about the prince that was
promised
there are a lot of similarities in both
prophecies and there are a couple of
references where they overlap. those
involve Maester Aemon. one time he asked
Melisandre about the prince that was
promised in relation to the war for the
dawn and another time he tells Samwell
that the prince would be born of salt
and smoke which is the same thing
Melisandre says about Azor Ahai. many
other of the theories that are
saying Azor Ahai and the prince that was
promised being different are also related
to Maester Aemon. he doesn't use the name
Azor Ahai when he talks about Daenerys
being the prince that was promised
but he's very aware that this
prophecy exists. we know this because he
left to Jade Compendium for John to read
which tells of the story Azor Ahai
and his sword Lightbringer. one big
difference is that you never really hear
people talking about the prince that was
promised wielding a sword like Azor
Ahai in that prophecy but there is a
reference to Rhaegar deciding to
become a night after he read something
in his Scrolls. meaning that he may have
uncovered something to the effect that
he needed to learn to handle a sword to
fulfill the prophecy
we also learned that the Prince part
isn't exactly right Aemon tells Sam that
high Valyrian is a gender-neutral
language and the dragons are neither
male or female
this meant that everyone was misled
thinking it was a prince for over a
thousand years
here are the signs of the coming of the
the prince that was promised. the birth of a
prince
(this could be wrong since Maester Aemon
says that it could be prince or princess
based on high Valyrian being
gender-neutral) the prince is the blood
of the Dragon. the woods witch would say
that it's specifically the blood that
comes from Aerys and Rhaella. born amidst
smoke. born amidst salt. a bleeding star
in the skies which has also been
mentioned like being born beneath the
bleeding star
there's also the possibility of the
return of dragons. this comes from the
dunk and egg stories when he was a boy
egg recalled that King Aerys the first
read about the return of dragons in a
prophecy. Aemon and Melisandre give us most of
the information about the prophecy and
they both have different ideas about who
fufills it. when he was young Aemon thought that it was Rhaegar and possibly
then his son Aegon until he was killed
during the sack of King's Landing. later
when Samuel tells him about Daenerys and
her dragons he immediately thinks it's
her. Melisandre thinks its Stannis until
he dies in the show and then says it's
Jon after he comes back to
life. for contrast these are the signs Azor
Ahai is reborn after a long summer
when the stars bleed in the cold breath
of darkness falls heavy on the world or
when the red star bleeds in the darkness
gathers he shall be born again
amidst smoke and salt he shall wake the
Dragons from stone he shall draw from
the fire burning sword which is
lightbringer. so there are a lot
similarities here the burning sword is
the major difference and it makes you
wonder how they aren't just a variation
of the same story after all prophecies
like that if the story has been passed
around for centuries it would likely
change as different cultures adopted it
and made it their own the great flood
myth is a good example of this in the
real world most people in Western
culture grew up learning that the story
about Noah and the Great Ark built in
preparation long before this story
appeared in the Bible that existed in
different cultures with different
details you know there's Gilgamesh and
there's there's many other different
examples from an objective non religious
viewpoint you might think that the
Christian faith co-opted this story
because it tells a great story of a
human craving life in the face of
calamity we know details related to the
prince that was promised sound very
Targaryen. Rhaegar says that Aegon is the
prince that was promised but then he
adds that there must be another because
the Dragon has three heads the name he
gave his children seem to suggest he
relates this to Aegon the Conqueror and
his to Sister Wives Rhaenys and Visenya
we don't know exactly why he connects
this to the prophecy but can agree that
this is a Targaryen specific kind of
detail on the other hand Melisandre
mentions the prince that was promised
without the Targaryen references in the
TV show Kinvars tells Tyrion that
Daenerys is the one that was promised
which i assume is just a general like
gender neutral way of saying it but
doesn't mention Lightbringer or dragon
with three heads all of this further
muddies the waters about whether the two
prophecies are from the same original
and have just morphed over time based on
cultures that means we can't deduce if
the prince that was promised and Azor
Ahai would be the same person if the
prophecy was fulfilled
there have been good theories written
for it being the same person, and there have
been good theories written about it
being two separate people at the end of
the day there are only two super strong
candidates which are Daenerys and Jon Snow
many of the other people that you could bring up just don't
really fit the bill
especially the way this you know the
story has developed overall Dany fits
the prince that was promised and also
woke dragons from stone she doesn't have
Lightbringer though and John seems like
a much better candidate to wield an
actual sword in battle against the White
Walkers at the same time he hasn't
woke any dragons and isn't in
possession
the flaming sword. So neither
fulfills the aspects of the Azure Ahai
version and on top of that we have the
Targaryen specific mention of the Dragon
having three heads for the prince that
was promised if you watch my importance
of prophecy video you know i think is
likely that the prophecy will be
fulfilled but what is really important
is that each of these characters stories
will be shaped by decisions they make in
relation to it in the books Jon is
still dead Stannis is still alive and
Daenerys far behind her story where she is
at you know in the show I think it's
safe to say that Jhn will be
resurrected engineers will make it to
Westeros how we get there probably won't
happen in the same way as it did in the
show but in the end I think the story is
leading to the same place so until the
winds of winter is released we can't say
for sure how the stories are going to
shake out the question is can we tell
how these prophecies will shape the end
of the story in the show
it's hard to say in general I would say
yes if this does give us a good idea
that there will be a big war coming
it will be a war for the dawn or a war
to be back the forces of the others
which would like to destroy humanity
I mean this is obvious for a lot of
reasons but we could just go with the
first thing that we hear about in the
prologue of the books and the first
thing we see in the show is the Nights
Watch coming in contact with the white
Walker from there we can agree that the
Iron Throne isn't what's important here
because the real threat to everything
has been building beyond the wall right
from the very start the show has
accelerated everything to the point that
we will experience the conclusion of the
story
pretty soon regardless of how you feel
about how they've done this we know that
the end they're working towards is based
on what george RR martin told them about
how he envisions the end of the story
major places they go should be
consistent
even though the details on how they get
there are different the showrunners know
who put who the prince that was promised
/ Azor Ahai is I find important that
they made sure to show young Ned place
or dawn at the foot of the bed where
Jon was born I mentioned at the
beginning that it was heavy-handed
because there's really no other reason
to make this part of the scene standout
Donna's house teens ancestral sword that
was forged from a following star and
also has you know the falling star right
on the hill they set this up to leave no
question that Jon Snow was born under a
bleeding sorry if you think there's
another reason to add this part of the
scene please
me know in the comments because I just
can't get around it does that in itself
mean that Jon Snow is as or high though
I mean definitely not after all Daenerys
is the one who woke the dragon is out of
stone and she's currently the only one
who is able to ride one of them i'm not
a big fan of the idea that the Dragons
themselves or Lightbringer and I don't
see Jon waking any other dragons from
stone anytime soon so that leaves us
with three possible conclusions
one more will be revealed to make either
Jon or Daenerys alone fulfill the proper
to Jon will fulfill one of the
prophecies and Dany will fulfill the
other or three
there's only one prophecy which is
fulfilled by both of them together it's
not a question of if one of them is the
prince that was promised in one is Azor
Ahai but instead it's that they are both
equally important to fulfill the
prophecy in the end so i don't know let
me know what you think I'm heavily
leaning towards the third option right
now like I said there's a ton of
interesting theories that have been
written for every possible outcome here
but I don't see either candidate taking
the lead in the race in the show most
theories are based on the books because
there's way more evidence to draw but at
the end of the day I do believe that
George has told the indie where to go if
not how to get there what happens in the
show matters but can't help us solve the
mystery
leave a comment and tell me what you
think Azor Ahai and the prince that was
promised teo different people?
is it the same person and you think you
know who it is how would you discount
either Jon or Dany and say that one is
more important than the other? is the
prophecy all a bunch of nothing that was
just basically woven into the story so
that we all waste a bunch of time trying
to figure it out please like the video
and subscribe to my channel i have a
giveaway going on for when i hit
eighteen thousand subscribers i'm giving
away a copy of a night of the seven
kingdoms which is the dunk and egg
stories and all you have to do is be a
subscriber and leave a comment so
awesome books and make sure you
subscribe now for your chance to win
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
soon